Good morning Hank; it's Tuesday.
I'm in my basement wearing a tie which can
only mean one thing: it's time for the Bank
of Nerdfighteria's semiannual report.
So the Bank of Nerdfighteria is like the U.S.
federal government (or an exceptionally unhealthy
tree) and has three branches.
There's the lending branch, the spending branch,
and then the giving branch.
Let's start with the lending branch over at
kiva.org.
More than 49,000 members of the Nerdfighter
Kiva group have loaned more than 6.3 million
dollars to entrepreneurs in the developing
world.
We're the second largest group of all time
on the website; you can make loans of as little
as $25 to the entrepreneur of your choice,
and you have a 99% chance of getting paid
back, so it's like a savings account with
a -1% interest rate, which is pretty healthy
these days.
There is a link in the doobly-doo below to
learn more.
OK, on to the spending arm.
So, Hank, our channels Crash Course and SciShow
are both primarily supported not by advertising,
but by voluntary subscriptions at Patreon.
Basically people who value Crash Course and
SciShow and can afford to support them can
go to Patreon and do so so that the rest of
us can watch it for free.
Hank, lots of people told us that this would
never work, but in fact so far, it's working
great.
Both Crash Course and SciShow are now not
only fully sustainable thanks to Patreon,
but we're hoping to be able to expand both
of them in 2016.
So, thank you.
There are also cool perks if you support the
shows on Patreon; there's a link in the doobly
doo.
And lastly, the giving arm.
So Hank, the 9th annual Project for Awesome
starts this Friday at noon Eastern time.
But the fundraising starts at midnight tonight
with the launch of Indiegogo with lots of
amazing perks with 100% of the proceeds going
to benefit the Foundation to Decrease World
Suck, which is the real name of our real charity,
and yes your donations are tax deductible.
The Foundation to Decrease World Suck has
no overhead; everyone who works on it volunteers
their time.
All that does it take money we raise during
the Project for Awesome and the rest of the
year and distribute it out to charities.
This year during the first half of the Project
for Awesome, we're raising money for Save
the Children and the UN's High Commission
on Refugees, and during that half of the P4A
your donation will be matched.
Save the Children donors have put up $350,000
of matching donations, and Hank and I are
going to match another 250,000.
So every dollar you donate for the first half
of the Project for Awesome will be matched,
and then in the second half, we're going to
be raising money for charities chosen by you.
Starting on Friday, you can go to projectforawesome.com,
watch P4A videos, and vote for your favorites,
so that nerdfighteria kind of collectively
picks what charities we support.
Also, if you have a charity that you feel
strongly about, you should make a Project
for Awesome video!
If you make an awesome video explaining why
a charity that you care about deserves people's
support, it could win lots of money - it happens
every year!
You can find lots of resources including Project
for Awesome thumbnails and stuff at projectforawesome.com;
there's a link in the doobly doo.
Also, during the Project for Awesome, there
is a 48 hour livestream, starring Hank and
myself and many other people from the YouTube
community.
During that 48 hours, you can always find
a link to the livestream at projectforawesome.com.
It's the one time of year when you're likely
to see my kids cover my face in sharpie.
Ah, I forgot to mention that before it even
starts, the Project for awesome is off to
a great start because the Foundation to Decrease
World Suck already has $80,000.
Most of that is either fro Nerdcrafteria (the
nerdfighter Minecraft server) or from Vlogbrothers
ad revenue, half of which goes to sponsor
educational projects online and half of which
goes to the foundation, so thank you for watching
ads!
So Hank, that's the status of the Bank of
Nerdfighteria, I'm very excited for the Project
for Awesome, if you have any questions you
can leave them in comments I will try to answer
them.
I've been pointing at my pants a lot in this
video.
Hank you will also see me on Friday because
it is my year to make a P4A video.
Hmm, so to even things out and bring order
to the universe, I will see you on both next
Tuesday and next Friday, then we'll return
to normal.
DFTBA.